people are listing iphones with fortnite
installed on ebay for thousands of
dollars
the next borderlands 3 dlc is coming
very soon and if you want to check out
the xbox series x's ui you can with the
new xbox one update
i'm chasity and this is your save save
for tuesday august 25th
[Music]
remember when ps4s with pt installed on
them became a rare item and then got
marked up on ebay while a similar thing
is happening now
with iphones with fortnite installed on
them due to the epic vs apple lawsuit
you can't currently play fortnite on
iphone unless you already downloaded it
this is leading to some people selling
iphones at ridiculous prices on ebay we
saw an iphone 11 with fortnite listed
for 5
000 this is a similar situation to when
pt was removed
from the playstation store leading
people to sell ps4s that still had the
game downloaded
the big difference is that fortnite on
iphone is tied to icloud accounts so
selling an iphone with fortnite on it
would mean it would have to be sent
unwiped and still connected to a
personal account obviously buying these
marked up phones is not recommended
epic not being able to push updates to
the game on iphone means eventually it
won't be playable on them at all
borderlands 3's next dlc is coming very
soon and it's a total foster clock
that's not an insult it's the name
psycho krieg and the fantastic buster
cluck say that five times fast comes to
borderlands 3 on all platforms on
september 10th
the plot involves dr tannis trying to
figure out why psychos are well
psycho this means you'll be going into
krieg's brain but all the loot you earn
inside can still be used in the real
world of the rest of the game
maya also appears inside krieg's mind
and she acts the way he pictures her
the same day the dlc launches there will
be a free level cap increase for all
players with a new max level of 65.
and note that this 4th dlc will be the
final edition covered by the borderlands
3 season pass
if you want to check out the xbox series
x's ui you now can with the new xbox one
update
the august 2020 update has begun rolling
out on xbox one making some changes to
the ui and adding some features
one big change is unlimited sign-ins
across devices with your account so you
can transition between them more
smoothly
this is good for bouncing between your
console xbox game pass on pc and xcloud
on android devices
the guide and activity feed have been
made more intuitive and you can set
individual volume levels for people in
your party
the ui you see in this update is the
same one you'll see on series x
including any updates before that time
and as a reminder the xbox series x
releases in november
that's it for the news but while you're
here we still have a few more days to
raise money for charity with the
gamespot store
head over to store.gamespot.com to buy
cool play for all merch including face
masks t-shirts hoodies and a very rad
skateboard
all proceeds go to charity until the end
of august so head to the store
get something cool and help us raise
money for a good cause
and that's your save save for tuesday
i'm chastity you can find me on twitter
at chastity underscore v
or find me talking about movies like the
batman and wonder woman 1984
over on youtube.com gamespot universe
i'll see you next time
you